if we consider a concrete house then the
whole structure is supported by a
meshwork
of iron rods as if these iron rods are
the skeleton of this house
similarly for our cell there are inner
meshwork of cytoskeletal elements which
involves several kinds of cytoskeletal
elements like acting based
microfilaments intermediate filaments
and microtubules which are made up of
two buing so in this video we'll be
talking about the microtubule its
properties its use and how it it helps
in cellular physiology obviously we
would look at it what are the
physiological cases where microtubule
dynamics is so important so stay tuned
till the end of this video so
microtubule dynamics is so important for
a cell's normal physiology it is
important for motility of cilia imagine
our lung epithelium which is ciliated
epithelium which need to beat its cilia
because mobility of multiple substances
so the cilia mobility is completely
dependent upon microtubule dynamics
imagine the neurons which are firing in
your brain needs the vesicle to be
transported at the end of the neurons to
the synapses and that could only happen
on top of a microtubule track right so
microtubule not only provides support to
the neuron it also helped in axonal
transport the cell division where we
have our microtubules pulling the
chromosomes towards the pole and thereby
the cell division can take place not
only that sperm motility is also
dependent upon microtubule dynamics
without the dynamic microtubule the
sperm would be no longer motile imagine
a neuron and you can see a portion of
that which is the axon of that and it
has multiple microtubules which are like
a tract
on which it has molecular motors kinase
ins which take vesicles from one side of
the neuron to this from the cell bodies
to the synapses and that's how our
neurons can fire and release the
neurotransmitter into the synaptic cleft
imagine a situation of inflammation
where your neutrophils your monocytes
need to squeeze themselves out of the
blood vessel and reach the place of
infant inflammation in that case this
squeezing through the narrow capillary
endothelial is e it is only possible
because the cytoskeletal elements inside
the blood inside these blood cells can
be rearranged which would allow them to
squeeze through now you can appreciate
that at several aspects of general
physiology and normal cell biology and
normal functionality of the cell the
microtubule dynamics is super important
so let's just focus on the structure of
the microtubule a little bit so
microtubule is basically a necklace of
alpha and beta tubulin dimer
so the basic subunit of the whole
microtubule is alpha and beta tubulin
dimer before we get into the structure
of alpha tubulin and beta tubulin we
should understand that microtubule is
nothing but a hollow rod and it can
occur in several formats in several
structures now the if we look at the
details of it we can understand that
alpha tubulin and beta tubulin are kind
of linked to each other forming a single
unit which would be polymerized to form
this microtubule the alpha tubulin and
beta tubulin is like 55 kilo Dalton
globular protein which has which is like
pretty much conserved across the across
all species and all classes now this
microtubule this microtubule constituent
which is like Tribune has gtp binding
sites in the interface of alpha and beta
tubulin this GTP is non-hydrolyzable but
whereas there is another gtp which is
bound to the beta tubulin which is
actually hydrolyzable
now this hydrolyzing the gtp has
consequences but whenever the beta
tubulin is gtp bound it can add new
subunits to the growing plus end of the
microtubule and help the microtubule to
polymerize but when the gtp is removed
and hydrolyzed to GDP microtubule starts
falling off my trusty bill starts
depolymerizing so all these things int
us to one factor that there should be a
critical concentration and people using
microscopic technique with live imaging
technique they found out if they tracks
a microtubule length over time they
found several times whether they the the
length of the microtubule shrink
dramatically and there are also events
when the length of the microtubule is
recovered so the event when the
microtubule length is going down
dramatically is known as catastrophe but
the microtubule is poly depolymerizing
rapidly whereas there is also a recovery
phase followed by that and all these
thing tells us that microtubule
polymerization and depolymerization is
pretty dynamic though this structure
providers mechanical support this this
structure provides the cell a mechanical
support but these structures are
dynamically unstable rapidly
polymerizing depolymerizing forming and
breaking down that's what gives the
dynamics to the cell itself now there is
a critical concentration beyond which
there could be polymerization or de
polymerization in an in vitro situation
there could be a concentration let's say
a critical concentration beyond which
there would be polymerization of the
microtubule and below that critical
concentration microtubule would start
falling off and P polymerize but inside
a cell the situation is different
because the tubulin dimer concentration
inside the cell is wave-wave way higher
than the critical concentration of the
polymerization and moreover there are
actors inside the cell which aid in
microtubule nucleation and help their
polymerization with keeping all these
things in mind it's easier inside the
cell or an in vivo situation to
polymerize the microtubule now inside
the cell there is some organelle known
as centrosome the centrosome has
centriole and pair essential or matrix
in the pair essential ER matrix there
are classes of protein which is known as
gamma tubulin ring complex gamma tubulin
ring complex is a super family of
tubulin which helps in nucleation and
help in polymerization of microtubule in
simple words gamma tubulin ring complex
works like an anchor holding it to the
microtubule organizing Center and
helping it to be stabilized and
polymerized now let's see what other
factors on which microtubule stability
depends on simply there are several
microtubule associated proteins are
known as maps which attach to the
microtubule and also tau proteins which
are pretty significant in terms of
Alzheimer's disease all affect the
microtubule dynamics and they help in
microtubule stability itself but there
are certain proteins like catenin and
stakman which help to sever the
microtubule from the end and try to
break down the microtubule so both kind
of factors are present in the cells
stabilizing and destabilizing factors in
other videos we would look at what are
the significance of having these
opposing kind of factor inside a cell
what are the clinical significance of
that now for now if you like this video
this is a very introductory video but if
you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you